hi guys Lucy here with a quick gamespot
news update for you Nintendo's
controversial new YouTube creators
program is already running into
difficulties it's only been a week a
brief overview then after google's cut
nintendo has the authority to take all
the ad revenue from any youtube video
that features it's copyrighted content
however if youtubers send their videos
to Nintendo for approval the ad revenue
will be split with the youtuber getting
roughly forty percent compared to the
sixty percent they'd usually get while
some complain that Nintendo is one of
the first companies to take a slice of
the content creators ad revenue others
take issue with Nintendo rewarding
positive coverage or at least content
that it approves with cash Nintendo says
that it has been inundated with requests
from YouTube personalities who want to
strike partnership deals and in fact the
backlog of requests has become so long
that the 72-hour wait time for video
approval has been extended the company
announced on its website due to your
enthusiasm for the program we're
receiving a higher volume of
applications to register channels and
videos than expected it is taking longer
than we anticipated to confirm the
applications we appreciate your patience
as we work through them as quickly as
possible a parent flood for requests for
video approval came days after prominent
youtubers including PewDiePie criticized
Nintendo for the terms and conditions of
its partnership program he took to his
tumblr to write I think this is a slap
in the face to the YouTube channels that
does focus on Nintendo game exclusively
the people who have helped and showed
passion for Nintendo's community are the
ones left in the dirt the most he
concluded there's just so many games out
there to play Nintendo games just went
to the bottom of that list so what do
you make of it all a Nintendo being
overly precious about their content or
youtubers just asking for too much let
us know in the comments section below
for all the latest on Nintendo make sure
you keep your eyes and ears on gamespot
com
you